hey youtubers is Charlie and it was just
revealed that Episode four of arrow the
seasons gonna be titled the magician
they tweeted the title page right before
they started filming Marc Guggenheim
included John Barrowman name in the
tweet so the title the magician probably
refers to Merlin the magician but it
could also be an Easter Egg for Satana
as well as other magical things inside
the arrow verse you also have to
remember that Guillermo del Toro has
also been talking a lot about Justice
League dark recently too so it gets you
thinking this video is mostly gonna be
an explanation for Merlin the magician
as in Malcolm Merlyn just because that's
what episode four is really gonna be
about magician is just one of his
nicknames from the comics but I'm also
gonna do some back story for Zatanna as
well as dr. fate Constantine and justice
lead arc and how the show might treat
them that they do a crossover and if
you're finding me for the first time I
do arrow videos every week so be sure to
subscribe to get everything
so magic on arrow not gonna happen just
yet it took Smallville till season 8 to
get there so the magician title of
episode 4 refers to Malcolm Merlyn his
original name in the comics before he
joined the League of Assassins was
arthur king eventually he took the stage
name Merlin the magician in Oliver
Queen's first few years as Green Arrow
in Star City Arthur challenged him to a
public archery contest Arthur or Malcolm
Merlyn as he was calling himself totally
got his ass handed to him and just
disappeared in disgrace eventually he
was recruited into the League of
Assassins and during his time there he
went on to tutor at the Cassandra Cain
Batgirl this was all before the new 52
reboot after the reboot his real name
was retconned to be Tommy Merlyn and of
course arrow the show went on to change
things just a little bit more so that
the character that John Barrowman plays
on the show is an amalgamation of the
old version of the character and the new
version so what does picking a title
like the magician say about the story
mostly I think it's gonna be John
Barrowman grand reintroduction to
Starling city
they'll have to explain what he was
doing while he was away the first time
during season two and then what he's
been doing since he came back for Thea
there is no guarantee that the is gonna
be part of the episode but since wil
Hahn is still a cast regular I'm
guessing she's gonna be around mostly
though it's just gonna be about Merlin
Merlin is Oliver's ultimate villain it's
like the relationship between grant
gustin's flash and professor zoom
Merlin's a little bit more of an
ambiguous villain than professor zoom
but what if they gave him his own Island
arc in season 3 not send Merlyn to the
island or anything like that I mean give
him a flashback story that would be told
one or more episodes so season to season
Oliver's flashbacks serve a really
important purpose yes they're totally
awesome to watch but they inform the
plot and present-day usually the
flashbacks tease things that are central
to each episode because Episode four is
titled the magician they could use a
flashback to tee up Merlin's grand plan
for season three remember way back in
the comics Oliver totally shamed him
during an archery contest so the show
could twist things just a little bit and
make Merlin shame Oliver in some public
way since it's pretty early in the
season in John Barrowman is a cast
regular whatever his story's gonna be
it's gonna take all season to tell so
they'll probably just be setting things
up and something else to get really
excited about usually when the show
picks a title that's right out of the
comic books they end up doing something
that's part of a really big comic book
story even if they change things a
little regardless of whatever references
they end up doing it's gonna be awesome
and it's gonna be all about Merlin and
his new plan there's also this meta
thing going on where John Barrowman
personality in real life makes me think
that Malcolm Merlyn in the episode is
gonna be really theatrical like he's
gonna be a stage performer just dancing
for the crowd for anyone who has not
seen John Barrowman at a convention in
real life he is totally over the top in
the best possible way he's a consummate
performer if you remember him from
Doctor Who or Torchwood whenever he got
to do a little more singing and dancing
that's what I'm thinking of Stephen
Amell already said that he flat-out
refused to do a musical episode of arrow
he was mostly joking but at the same
time Malcolm Merlyn I think is gonna be
very flamboyant without being funny
picture him giving off more of a Tom
Hiddleston low-key vibe you know just
having fun being in the spotlight again
in the sense of the story Malcolm being
back in the public eye inside Starling
city as for what I think he was doing
during the break I mostly think he was
training Thea and laying the groundwork
for whatever his takeover plan is
something that would restore a lot of
his lost power remember he lost his
company just like Oliver lost his so
Merlin and Oliver's still share a lot in
common
Thea's storyline is a little bit easier
to predict but I have no idea what
Merlin's grant plan is going to be I
just think that he's going to be taking
advantage of Oliver being very
distracted will AHA and actually posted
this picture to Instagram recently it's
just her working out with a hardcore
trainer in terms of persona or comic
book characters I think that she's going
to be closer to Artemis they'll just
change Artemis's backstory the way they
changed Isabel rochev to make her
Ravager and if you needed more evidence
forget that dia also had archery
trophies inside her bedroom her
motivation in season three is just a
little unclear right now but I am so
looking forward to her getting a big
fight scene with Roy she's gonna be so
much fun just to clarify my earlier
Merlin point when I was talking about
Oliver being distracted I was mostly
referring to the new villains count
vertigo and Ra's al Ghul occupying the
biggest part of his headspace and his
other remaining brain cells being spent
thinking about Felicity Ray Palmer and
everyone else so it just seems like
Merlyn would use that situation to take
advantage of Oliver so now time to talk
about Satana dr. fate Constantine
Justice League dark inside the
arrowverse magic right now totally does
not exist inside the arrow verse but the
producers of all the different DC TV
shows are open to the idea of crossovers
so until there's a strong plan in place
for arrow and Constantine to start
referencing each other
Satana has a better chance of showing up
inside a Constantine episode just
because they're already dealing with
that type of subject matter because of
the way they tease dr. fate in the
Constantine Premiere I think the
Constantine is gonna wait till season 2
before it does any big big comic book
characters they'll probably follow the
arrow model stick to core characters in
the first season and if it gets renewed
which I think it will use season 2 to
bring in more comic book characters like
Satana would be a really easy sell
Constantine is already rooted in the
idea of magic and supernatural powers
so escalating things just a little bit
let's move on to Guillermo del Toro and
Justice League dark he has a finished
script it's been in development for a
long time he said he totally wants to
make Constantine part of the team as in
TV Constantine that doesn't mean it's
gonna happen but think about it this way
the TV shows in the movies are not gonna
have any kind of crossover so consider
them separate universes I think the
chances are pretty good we could see a
TV version of Justice League dark way
before they ever tried it as a movie
plus via arrow in the flash
they can also do a modified Justice
Society doing Justice Society just makes
it easier for them to use characters
that don't step on the toes of the movie
characters they're just getting started
with the flash though so I don't expect
anything like that for at least another
season or two but if they did it on
Smallville they can totally do it again
but let me know would you rather see
Justice League dark done on TV via like
the Konstantin arrow universe and do you
think that arrow and the flash are gonna
get to just a society before Zack Snyder
in the movie people get to Justice
League I say yes
to both Justice League dark on TV is a
no-brainer Kim altura always seems like
the busiest man on the planet and he's
developing Pacific Rim too so he might
not be able to participate if it happens
which is a bummer but the Justice League
movie is not playing until 2017
that's almost season six of arrow so I
definitely think that the flash and
arrow can get to their team-up way
before then right now I'm planning
videos for my favorite Justice League
dark and favorite Justice Society
stories so be sure to subscribe to get
those there has been some movie news and
I'll explain in just a second right now
the biggest rumor is is that Lex Luthor
is going to be cloning a Kryptonian at
the end of Batman vs Superman and he's
going to synthesize kryptonite it's just
a rumor but I will do a video if it
turns into something bigger just because
the guardians of the galaxy being so
popular right now I think there's been a
whole lot of like superhero team-up talk
in the meantime they learn all about
marvel's Inhumans movie by clicking here
and you can click here to learn all
about Wildcat that take grant Wildcat
coming on arrow season 3 it's gonna be
so much fun thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you